right now is wisconsin senator ron
johnson senator it's good to see you
tonight thanks very much for joining us
assess all of these executive orders how
has the senate been
under joe biden's presidency
well he doesn't need the senate he's
just using his pen and phone
i guess he's just flooding the zone and
he's just satisfying every desire of the
radical left wing of his party
he's not moderate at all and i i don't
know he said you know we have to
call out the lies you know what you just
played in in the lead up to this
interview
sounded like a lie to me when he said
that he was going to you know not be a
dictator
he was going to actually utilize the
senate and try and get the votes
he hasn't tried to get any vote
whatsoever so far in terms of policy so
what what strikes you the most in terms
of these uh policies that we're seeing
through
executive order i want to get to uh the
biden family in a moment but first
tell me about the executive orders and
where you see
the biggest issue today of course it was
about health care
well as the former chairman of homeland
security government affairs committee
we we spent so much time looking at our
completely broken border
and what we need to do to fix it of
course president trump went a long way
toward
stopping the in the the surge in
unaccompanied children and family units
uh taking a very dangerous journey
we had not completely solved that
problem but we had truly mitigated it
we were building the fence and here
president biden comes along
and starts undoing all of the progress
we had made
and we're going to see another
humanitarian disaster we're seeing
we saw 9 000 people trying to get
through guatemala from honduras
it's something like another care van is
forming they may come in smaller groups
but they will come
because they realize they're going to be
able to stay because it's going to be
open border policy it's going to be
catch and release it's going to be a
disaster
yeah well this really hits to people's
worries about security
look what has happened with the end of
cash bail
uh in in new york you're seeing
shootings up in the double digits you're
seeing crime rising
we just don't know who's coming in
no we're going to find out what liberal
policies impact is
on every day american lives and it's not
going to be pretty
it's it's again we won't have border
security we're seeing murder
rates increase in democrat-controlled
cities
this is going to continue it's it's not
going to be good murray it's not going
to be good
senator let me let me move on to the
biden family apparently still using joe
and joe's name for business look at this
uh
ad that joe biden's brother
has been promoting this is frank biden
and he's promoting his relationship to
his brother the commander-in-chief
in an inauguration day advertisement for
the law firm
that he advises frank biden is a
non-attorney senior advisor for the
berman law group in an email
he says he's not used his brother's name
to gain clients and yet there's an
ad out right now and was around the uh
uh
inauguration bragging that his brother
is the commander-in-chief
this is way too reminiscent of what we
saw with hunter biden
whereas he was gaining relationships
getting paid for it from international
companies
because of the influence that his
brother
his father commanded well
biden inc is still in business and maria
i just ask you
what does a senior non-attorney adviser
do
in a law firm he makes connections he
peddles his influence and there was
another report
by the way that hunter biden was you
know apparently he was supposed to give
up all his ownership in these uh
chinese companies but a report came out
yesterday that the city still apparently
has his 10
stake in bhr that private equity firm in
china
uh that ought to be very troubling i
haven't heard him deny that uh
i'm hoping it's not true because again
that that
raises so many troubling counter
intelligence extortion types of threats
again biden inc is back in business if
it ever went out and i don't think it
ever did
of course we can't talk about this on
social media because
you will be labeled you will be attacked
because you're talking about a truthful
story